Này 3.5, công hán thình vũ đàn hẳng định thông tin lan chuyên trên mạng xã hội việc một người nước ngoài
bắt cóp đứa sinh tại phương này hinh đông, quận xương trả là hoàn toàn sai sự thật.
Chứ đó, một tài khoản phía sbu quốc đăng tài nổi dung cho rằng một người đàn ông Quốc
tịch công phu xia đã dủ dấu giấu và bắt cóp một nước sinh bằng tù đạn cho quả và bỏ thu mề.
Puy nhiên, qua sát miền, công hán địa phương xã định người đàn ông trong vụ việc là ông Zé,
2 mi chính tuổi, cuối tịch Trung Quốc đã quen biết cháu nở nửa tế hát, mùi bá tuổi, qua mạng xã hội và hành tập tài khoản cà phê.
Sau cuộc gặp, ông Zé có sây công nghệ dời đi và bị người thân chó hát chận lại vì như,
không có dấu hiệu bắt cóp hay sâm hạnh nào sẽ ra, 2 bên đa hoa dài và không có yêu cầu hiểu này.
Công ăn thình phủ đàn nắng đám dối 2 cân nhân đăng tài thông tin xa sự thật lên làm việc.
Cả hai thường dẫn chiếc xảy thông tin trước kìm chứng và càng kết không tài phạc.